[Music]
have you ever thought about ordering a
lift by controlling your thoughts
nor had i until i met matiere krantz
chief technology officer at finnish
elevator maker connect
corner has partnered with tech firm
unseen to make a mind-controlled
elevator this
electroencephalogram headset measures
neurons activities of our brains and the
data will be processed by ai to make a
command but first you have to teach the
device to understand a thought pattern
such as playing an instrument which is
then used to command the elevator
i'm now going to be thinking about my
favorite hobby which is playing guitar
and i'll find out whether i can order a
lift by doing that
hold on
[Music]
and here it is
as such this kind of eeg technology is
sensing people's brain this is decades
of science but uh now what we have is
actually you can have this kind of
smaller size devices with the simple
sensors to measure your brain activity
at kona we design connected elevators
and you can connect all kinds of devices
from wheelchairs to your
telephones
and control your elevator and you can
even use uh your mind to bring the
elevator up and down and we hope that in
the future this is how we'll be
interacting with infrastructure
including the elevators in our buildings
corner wants to showcase what's possible
when the devices like elevators are
connected through this experiment
currently though it has no plans to
offer it to customers